no início desse ano de novo me propus a
fazer as coisas que mais gosta
a primeira é ficar em casa a segunda é
ficar em casa lendo
a terceira é ficar em casa trabalhando
ea quarta é ficar em casa e vivendo a
minha vida
então agora que vocês já sabem com a dor
ficar em casa
vou contar mais uma característica minha
eu sou tímida
muitas pessoas que gostam tanto de ficar
em casa é porque são ao meu caso sou
muito tímida
pois bem eu estava na minha casa como
tanto gosto quando recebi um telefonema
da 10min convidando para um tal de ted
que eu nem sabia o que era verdade nunca
tinha assistido tese mas há de se estar
a explicar as coisas de um jeito que
logo a gente tente ela falou com aquele
sotaque pernambucano
a menina você vai se apresentar com as
pessoas no fim do ano lá no museu da
arte do rio
não entendi nada aí osku tô te
convidando para contar sua história no
ténis x pedra do sal
o curso de preparação começa semana que
vem a sócia esteja vocês acham que isso
é convite é assim uma intimação mas há
desde que me conhece há muito tempo sabe
que além de gostar de ficar em casa e
ser tímida tem ainda uma terceira
característica sou muito curiosa
acho que isso vem de tanto ler nem tudo
que é livro muito rápido só de
curiosidade em saber o que acontece no
final pois então foi minha curiosidade
que me ajudou está aqui hoje
neste palco depois de vencer suas duas
grandes concorrentes
minha vontade é ficar em casa e minha
timidez
tive muita curiosidade em conhecer as
pessoas que vieram ouvir uma história
que acha que não merece ser contada
nunca tinha enfrentado com a platéia
desse tamanho na verdade protege
qualquer tamanho nunca me apresentei
antes
e quando percebi contar uma história
descobri que tinha muitas coisas que eu
não queria contar
aí fiquei num dilema como vou contar uma
história se tem tantas coisas que eu não
quero contar
foi nesta hora cara a cara com este
dilema que resolveria a questão foi a
minha quarta característica que veio com
força total
adoro desafios muito prazer meu nome é
patrícia pereira tem 32 anos e você já
sabe
adoro ficar em casa 2 sou tímida
3 sou muito curiosa e quarto
adoro desafios é vou comprar a facilitar
minha vida e homenagear tanto nativas
que já lhe vou começar como nos velhos
contos era uma vez uma moça que o dólar
adorava ler histórias
eu mesmo mas nunca tinha pensado em
conta a sua e não sabia bem como fazer
então decidi que vou começar pela parte
mais difícil pra me livrar logo vou
dizer os motivos pelos quais a minha
história não merece ser contada
primeiro não quero reviver a noite que o
tarado me atacou o segundo
não quero falar de religião nem chutou
minha fé
3º não quero parecer e segura na
ignorante e quarto e último não quer
principalmente que saibam como eu era
medrosa
pronto agora falei falei a parte mais
difícil
vamos em frente o cretino que me atacou
não faz idéia de como o do metrô a
vitória
quero ressaltar que não importa o
tamanho da sua roupa
ninguém merece passar por tamanha
violência
eu decidi reagir e só não morri naquela
noite porque consegui soltar uma mão e
tirar o dele da minha traquéia e gritar
pedindo ajuda
uma pessoa que estava passando veio
correndo no encontro o tarado fugiu ao
sair dessa com apenas alguns arranhões
os pontos na cabeça mas a dor no meu
pescoço perdurou por muito tempo eo medo
de de repente alguém por trás de mim me
atacar com uma gravata
eu tenho até hoje
só quem já passou por isso conhece um
medo irracional de que aconteça
novamente
a tentativa de estupro me fez ter medo
de sair sozinha por isso precisei mudar
de igreja
passei a congregar na igreja dos meus
pais
e foi aí que eu ganhei um presente muito
valioso
meu pai é um homem muito trabalhador que
mesmo doente se recusava a depender
financeiramente do x trabalhava tanto
que quase não tivemos até que ele
resolveu que ia me levar todas as vezes
que eu fosse à igreja além de me
acompanhar
ele conversava muito comigo descobrir
ali com o homem que mesmo um
semianalfabeto era muito sabe
conhecedor de muitos detalhes da vida um
exemplo de honestidade e dedicação à
família
tempos depois ele faleceu mas deixei
minha certeza de que ouvi histórias boas
histórias podem mudar nossa vida
seguindo a minha história fala pra vocês
sobre o segundo homem da minha vida meu
marido não queres pollo mas a doença
dele é o motivo pelo qual nunca procurei
emprego ainda tem muito preconceito com
quem tem esquizofrenia e eu ficava em
casa para ajudá-lo a ter uma vida melhor
mas o tempo foi passando e o dinheiro
ficando cada vez mais escasso e foi
nesta neste momento que dentro da minha
fé
orei pedindo uma idéia de como conseguir
dinheiro eu estava tão cansada sabe
quando seu corpo todo dói eu me deixei
cair na cama e na mesma hora senti que
tinha caído em alguma coisa
olhei e era uma embalagem de trufas sim
dessas trufas de chocolate
ficamos encarando eu e aquela embalagem
e me dê conta de que pra comprar
chocolate que desceu o morro são
moradores de uma comunidade que fica na
tijuca
moro lencinho isso aqui pensando nas
pessoas que como eu que amo chocolate
shutter que descer e andar térreo
uruguai para comprar esses pensamentos
ficar
rosiana aqui dentro por um tempo e
sempre tive o sonho secreto de ter meu
próprio negócio
tinha medo de passar a vida toda apenas
como dona de casa
pois bem enquanto esses pensamentos
amadureciam surgiu a oportunidade de
conhecer o negócio na igreja e dar uma
festa então sugerir venda de trufas de
chocolate porque todo mundo adora e
daria uma boa fonte de receita
só que eu não tinha a menor experiência
no assunto
então pedi pra outra pessoa fazer pois
ela já tinha trabalhado com chocolate
ante tudo certo mas na hora h a pessoa
eu acordo e sumiu
me deixou na mão por um motivo que até
hoje não entende mas a fé é isso
acredito que foi uma forma de deus
colocar uma profissão meu caminho
eu já tinha prometido vender e doar o
dinheiro para a festa
sou muito comprometida como promessa
para mim se prometeu tem que cumprir
então não teve jeito conseguir uma
receita e fiz não é que conquistei meu
primeiro cliente
no início eu não sabia usar o computador
nem fazia idéia do que era o youtube mas
foi no youtube que aprendíamos menos
receitas
comecei com três sabores já tenho mais
de 20
também recebi o convite para fazer um
curso de empreendedor ine
confesso pra vocês perceberam e não me
sinto à vontade no meio de pessoas que
não conheço mais fui e com essas pessoas
aprendi a gerir aprendi a vender e
graças a elas vendo mais de 300 triunfos
por semana e sabem quem é meu vender o
meu marido que vai de porta em porta na
comunidade na ruas próximas cantando
olha trompa
as trufas deram um novo sentido à minha
vida também para o meu marido que é meu
maior incentivador
elas têm sido uma terapia para ele que
conheceu pessoas com doenças parecida
com a dele e é um exemplo para quem quer
abandonar o tratamento pois a fé é
importante mas os medicamentos também
são
ele adora vender e conhece todo mundo na
comunidade
ele ficou tão famoso que por onde ele
passa as pessoas a ponta enquanto olha o
trufa
como você já sabe que eu adoro ficar em
casa pode imaginar como é fundamental
para o meu negócio tem alguém que sai
com alegria pelas ruas e vielas cantando
que está vendendo a melhor trunfo do rio
agora eu já não fico mais constrangida
quando pergunto minha profissão eu
queria ser mais que uma dona de casa e
consegui hoje continuam gostando de
ficar em casa e continuo tímida mas como
fruto da minha curiosidade e gosto por
desafio
sou artesã chocolate e micro
empreendedora e muitas outras coisas que
ainda nem descobrir no início da minha
fala estava tentando explicar para vocês
porque minha história não merece ter
contado achava que mistura a agressão
com fé com a segurança eo meu lado
medroso cunha da boa coisa
mas agradeço a vocês a oportunidade de
ver se este tremendo desafio de olhar
para tudo o que me aconteceu entender
que essa história não sei que mensagem
ela transmite mas sei que essa é a minha
verdadeira história
agora meu último segredo já cobrindo o
coração
o final dessa história depende de vocês
se eu começar a falar
e vocês começarem a cochilar você já
mexer no celular
minha fase final seria esta é a história
que não merece ser contada
mas hoje foi o contrário visualize me
acompanhando durante esses minutos como
atenção paciência e curiosidade então
pra vocês por vocês minha frase final é
minha história
s sim ser contada muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]